[Music]
whether you are still a kid or already a
grown-up there is probably a cartoon or
anime that you just can't stop watching
unfortunately you might not have the
chance to know about some of the best TV
shows in the world because your country
banned them and we're here to tell you
about them anyway just wait until you
see why Pokemon was banned around the
world after sending 600 kids to the
hospital if you love cartoons as much as
we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you ten cartoons
banned in other countries Winnie the
Pooh just when you thought that nothing
could go wrong with a sweet character
trying to ban the bear on the internet
for a ridiculous reason it's been
several years since the Internet users
started comparing the cartoon character
to the Chinese President Xi Jinping you
can see the pictures of Winnie the Pooh
and Tigger walking together being
compared to the picture of Jinping and
former President Barack Obama you can
also see the president shaking hands
with Japanese Prime Minister Abe a sings
oh and it's once again compared to
Winnie and his friend Eeyore and these
are not the only pictures as Internet
users keep having fun with this running
gag but it seems like it went too far as
it became the most censored image in
China in 2015 we don't understand why
she's UMP would take it so personally we
need the Pooh is a character that
everyone loves and it shouldn't be a bad
thing to be associated with them however
cyber officials claim that they didn't
like to see their president being
compared to a slow witted and naive bear
that is why if anyone in China tried to
find a picture of the comparison they
would not be able to find the result if
Internet users tried to talk about
Winnie the Pooh in any comments a
message would pop up and tell them that
it was against Chinese law we hope that
she's Jinping will learn to laugh at the
joke because we would love to see him
smile like the cartoon character the
loud house this cartoon is down the most
popular show on Nickelodeon becoming a
number-one children's animated series on
television within its first month on the
air
unfortunately in Kenya it will never
have the chance to become popular
because the cartoon has been banned the
reason for this is that it's the first
time we got a chance to see queer
characters including the gay married
couple on a Nickelodeon cartoon they're
not the only two men in love there are
also Clyde's parents and an interracial
couple Lincoln was right to say that it
was time to make history right before
opening the door it was finally time
that we saw some diversity in kids
cartoons unfortunately some countries
weren't ready for that and they received
many complaints from viewers
Kenya's
filming classification board suspended
many children's programs accusing them
of featuring disturbing content
glorifying homosexual behavior they said
that adults can choose to be homosexuals
and exercise their rights on sexual
orientation and relationships but not so
with children we hope that they will
change their minds not only because the
loud house is a great cartoon but also
so children can grow up knowing that
it's okay to be different
peppa pig if you have a kid or a little
sister at home you probably have already
watched Peppa Pig and don't be shy if
you watched it on your own even if you
are grown up we all love kids shows
sometimes and they teach us good life
lessons unfortunately one of the
episodes was inappropriate for
Australian viewers this is why the
country had to ban it but what did Papa
do this time in the 5 minute episode
called spider's web the family met a new
character a spider named mr. skinnylegs
they took the time to get to know him
and learn that they shouldn't be scared
of spiders and that they should avoid
disturbing his web if you can't still
figure out what's wrong with this
cartoon you probably don't know that
many spiders are really dangerous in
Australia some of the world's most
venomous spiders live in the country
this is why Australian children should
never believe that spiders can be their
friends and there are a lot of reasons
why they should be scared of them when
ABC heard about this they immediately
apologized for running it and said they
have been restricted from being aired on
the ABC television networks so don't
worry there are still more episodes of
Peppa Pig that you can watch in
Australia South Park it's absolutely not
a surprise to hear that South Park was
banned in many countries it's probably
one of the most controversial cartoons
in the world and we think that you
shouldn't be watching it unless you're a
grown-up who has a critical mind many
people think that the show went on a
little too far and some of the most
shocking episodes were 200 and 201 for
the 200th episode of South Park the
creator's decided to push the limits by
depicting the Prophet Mohammed it set
off controversy across the globe as it
was obviously an offense to Muslims even
those who don't have religious beliefs
were shocked to hear the cartoon would
dare to do that the show have been
running in India for less than a year
and it was abruptly taken off the air
Indian viewers didn't even have time to
see the 200th episode and it was already
too much for them Russia also tried to
ban the cartoon to replace it with
program teaching children to be
patriotic if you think that these
countries are too close-minded
you'll be surprised to hear that the US
has a ban on part of the show too Comedy
Central censured Mohammed by placing
black bars over the characters and
cutting
his lines the show was then pulled out
from the air and it was not possible to
see the episode on the website or in
repeats sailormoon we love to see
powerful female characters become heroes
in one of our favorite anime
however viewers around the world were
not shocked by the fights but by the
love between some of the characters in
the original anime Sailor Neptune and
Sailor Uranus or two women who fell in
love with each other even though
Japanese viewers had the chance to see
the two characters dating their
relationship was banned in many
countries including America as they
couldn't just get rid of these two
characters they had to rewrite a new
story instead in the United States they
transforms Neptune and Uranus into
cousins it is strange to think that
family members flirting with each other
was more appropriate for Americans than
to women in love they were not the only
characters who had to pretend that love
is only between a man and a woman Zozi
was changed into a woman to explain why
he was dating another male villain in
the first season there was also a whole
season that Americans did not get a
chance to see because it featured
characters who changed gender when they
transformed so this time Japanese
viewers were the ones who thought that
America was the other country that
banned homosexuality and their anime The
Simpsons it's no surprise that our
favorite Homer Simpson did something
shocking once again but for what reason
could he be banned from a country well
have to tell you why most of the
characters are yellow Matt Groening the
creator of The Simpsons simply love the
idea that whatever someone was flipping
their channels they would automatically
know that they're watching their
favorite cartoon as many of them saw the
yellow bodies this is probably one of
the reasons it's the longest running
American sitcom
after more than 600 episodes the cartoon
is still really popular but not in Mayan
maar this country in Asia the movie was
banned because of political reasons but
this was not for the reasons that you
might think as the story or the topics
had nothing to do with that the
juxtaposition was the colors red and
yellow were not allowed in the film at
the time because these color were used
in support of rebel groups within the
nation as Lisa and Bart could have
yellow skin and wear clothes that could
look orange or red my admirer saw the
movie as a threat we know that it was
not the intention of the American
creators but the country was a little
more superstitious at that time
unfortunately people in the country
didn't have the chance to get to see the
famous spider pig song stuck in their
heads Steven universe we all love this
unique cartoon so we all feel bad that
we learned that it was banned in the
country and that kids
be watching it Steven universe is
another victim of the van of Kenya after
the country claimed that some cartoons
were glorifying homosexual behavior easy
he'll Matua the chief executive officer
of the regulator so that his institution
received complaints about the shows he
even thought that those who did not
complain were just aware of the
progressive and bizarre messages
intended to promote gay agenda Steven
universe has been known for being one of
the greatest career shows on TV
unfortunately some countries including
the United States and the UK thought it
was not appropriate for young children
this is why the show has been marked
with a PG rating and some scenes were
edited people were so shocked to see
Ruby kissing sapphire the people started
a petition online they asked Cartoon
Network to censor previous episodes and
exclude LGBT themes in future episodes
but then fans started to get another
petition as encouraging network to stop
censoring queer content in Steven
universe almost 10,000 people signed for
diversity while fewer than 200 stills
after the cartoon was not appropriate
for kids it's a male and a female can do
it why can't we see two female
characters in love on TV Family Guy
we know that this family is really
controversial but we do want to know
what they did to deserve to be banned
from a country it's not surprising that
some people thought the Family Guy was
inappropriate but it is shocking to know
that it was banned in Russia Malaysia
India Venezuela South Korea South Africa
the Philippines Taiwan Egypt Indonesia
Vietnam and Iran and let's not forget at
least a dozen episodes that have been
banned all around the world including
the United States not a lot of the
cartoons say that they are one of the
most controversial animated series in
the world and if you think that these
countries are close-minded don't forget
that the United States didn't always
appreciate the show either Fox decided
not to air an episode of Family Guy
because it included too many sensitive
topics this is when creator of the show
Seth MacFarlane decided to speak out
about censorship is that the people in
America are becoming less intelligent
they're getting less and less able to
analyze something and think critically
and pick apart the underlying elements
and more and more ready to make a snap
judgment regarding something at face
value which is too bad but should we
really have the right to watch anything
on TV MacFarlane probably didn't think
about kids watching the show Pokemon
this anime wanted to be the very best
like no other animated series ever was
unfortunately
failed in the worst way in December 1997
when Japanese kids sat down to watch
episode of their favorite anime almost
700 never saw the end of electric
soldier porygon more than 600 children
had to go to the hospital after they
were watching the show and more than 100
of them are still hospitalized the day
after but what happened many of them
experienced seizures when Pikachu used
his lightning power to blow up some
missiles some of them also passed out
experience blurred vision or felt
nauseous about 1 in 4,000 people can
suffer from photosensitive seizures with
4 million people watching the show in
Japan we understand why they would be
affected to create a special effect in
the virtual world the animators used a
rapidly strobing technique that flashed
red and blue lights on the screen
unfortunately it was too late when they
realized their mistake the episode was
banned from airing again even in edited
form all around the world but Japan went
further than that the show was taken off
the air for four months and Nintendo was
negatively affected but the show is so
good we forgive them now and the problem
is solved spongebob squarepants our
favorite cartoon character might live in
a pineapple under the sea but he doesn't
live anywhere near Ukraine or China
China had a good reason to ban the
animated series in 2006 the country
decided to prevent foreign cartoons from
being screened during the golden hours
from 5 p.m. to 9 p.m. this is because
they wanted kids to get the chance to
watch animated series created by Chinese
artists and encouraged their own cartoon
industry we're not against the ban and
actually I think it could be a good idea
but the reason why a Ukrainian group
wanted to ban the cartoon was much more
ridiculous once again they thought that
SpongeBob SquarePants promoted
homosexuality they thought that this
show is part of a master plan a large
scale experiment on Ukrainian children
to create criminals if you don't know
what they're talking about you're not
the only one we think that it has
something to do with the fact that
Sponge Bob is popular with the gay
community
however the creator said that the
character was asexual so people clearly
loved his personality do you think that
we should be allowed to watch anything
on television or do you think we still
need censorship don't be trying to tell
us what you think in the comment section
down below we'd love to hear your
opinion and that's it for 10 cartoons
banned in other countries for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
strange reasons why Disney movies were
banned thanks for watching
[Music]